welcome to this video this is what am i
doing him this is a viewer challenge so
it's three to turn control playing two
games against fisticuffs to challenge me
and playing the Kalashnikov variation of
the Sicilian I don't know where this
name comes from to be honest I thought
to have no idea there is no player
called Kalashnikov and they're not quite
sure how it relates to the to the weapon
alright so we have a normal position
Knight f6 Bishop g5 is one possibility
night here I don't know now let's let's
play that note that this is another
rating let's say rating pool with an ICC
so the ratings here are completely
different from the ones in the normal
five-minute games that I play like m25
is higher than my five-minute rating but
in this rating type there are many
players in close to 3000 so too largely
ignore those my opponent is some is a
master player from the US i read the the
notes ok so we relatively quickly set up
a position from the sheshna cough and
it's the usual complicated position
let's see well it's about the d5 square
and it's about f5 Dwight has some has a
form I maybe should have played a 5 so
that I'm able to ok for maybe can just
take ok
hmm Jim I also could have played 97 yeah
I don't know it's been a while since I
played the shredder cough and a
tournament game I played that quite
often before I switch to e5 I was mainly
a Sicilian player okay he's taking lots
of time of course it's not an easy
position I mean there are many possible
possible setups hmm yeah should I good
night e7 a.m. it's a it's a possibility
and he's got this a fool's not sure like
I probably just need to take this and
then get the counter play against be too
yeah 97's strategically it's not clear
if that's a good move but at the moment
I don't see him getting a substantial
control ok yeah all night here if I go
here I might take with the pawn but not
sure that this is great he didn't take
with the bone
okay so what about this position I mean
the family without managed to take on d5
and he needs to recapture with the pawn
everything's fine okay I can go here
actually if he goes night before I have
Quincy eight attending a five Quincy
eight covers a 66 all the sensitive
squares or maybe even Queen B 6 yeah
this should be should be okay really
nothing to fear here a form a BM if for
has gained somewhat and strength us now
the queen is always protecting between
but maybe a four I take Queen and then
Queen B 6 simply or before okay let's
let's make sure that there's a pawn on
d5 and no peace CD is virtually they are
not playable because I control the CFR
hmm before or take yeah I guess taking I
can show the importance e1 square so
that is somewhat easier to play for
black this position yeah I can give the
check should i do that yeah I guess so
and then get the bishop here somewhat
now f farm look at five rook h5 and then
made on edge to wear this would be nice
but not so easy to have to accomplish
now it's not not tarrant how I'm
actually making progress it's clear that
this is a nice position oh ok I don't
mind to have those pawns I mean maybe
you can block them yeah like that but
still it feels like I gain to something
here maybe get to the h born rook edge
for gadget White has no particular play
besides that which are completely
overlooked Wow yeah I simply forgot
about the possibility
have no way to protect this yeah yeah I
really made the conscious effort to play
quickly
unbelievable on check the air light was
completely outplayed already like really
lost yeah yeah what crap is this sorry I
simply overlooked the TA text g6 before
that white is basically lost in this
position just just lost 44 no for
nothing but after after Bishop DS after
that it cannot I cannot protect it I
need to I overlooked Bishop b5 check of
course after Queen d8 like it's still
okay probably just because white is so
so verse that I can I can still continue
here yeah I'm threatening rook h2
winning it's it's still okay he may be
needs to go for some kind of draw or
okay too yeah I just need to do
something that not blunders g6 queen d 8
is minus 34 m for starters here and so
on it just completely gone not sure what
the what the arrows are doing ok so we
won the first one and we do a rematch
thanks for watching